un sujet maintenant au croisement de
deux phénomènes de société de plus en
plus de propriétaires choisissent
l'autoconstruction en parallèle ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux à choisir de
vivre dans des tiny house vidéo et tuto
pullules sur internet pour aider à
construire soi-même son logement mais se
lancer dans un tel chantier n'est pas
simple même pour une maison au format
réduit à Cuesmes au nord-ouest de
l'Indre-et-Loire un atelier propose de
vous aider dans l'auto-construction
Aurélie Renan
depuis trois mois Juliette passe tout
son temps dans cette entrepôt on y
construit des tiny house pourtant
Juliette n'est pas une salariée elle
loue une partie du local pour construire
sa propre petite maison Juliette et son
ami se sont donnés un an pour fabriquer
leur propre petit habitat de 18 mètres
carrés et pourtant le couple n'était pas
bricoleur il y a des soirs terribles
on va y retourner demain vraiment là il
y a des jours où on passe une journée
entière à faire quelque chose et on
l'arrache le soir parce qu'en fait
c'était pas bon donc ça c'est les jours
très difficiles beaucoup de charges
mentales en fait et mais il faut
apprendre qu'il y a des jours où ça
n'avance pas et puis après d'un coup ça
avance mais incroyablement en trois
jours
l'autoconstruction de la tiny réduit le
coût final de plus de la moitié 30 000
euros pourraient suffire à bâtir la
petite tiny de Juliette pour les
conseils et les choix de matériaux elle
consulte les tutos de la communauté tiny
sur internet pour le reste elle compte
sur le couple de professionnels qui lui
loue les locaux ils viennent avec le
savoir qu'ils ont et les compétences
qu'ils ont et en fonction de ça nous on
leur propose soit de l'aide manuelle
soit de l'aide juste technique